hello and welcome to this video what
kind of writing is that term 659 are you
insane jus llamo Sebastian Vasquez
Coleman okay I've got a plus one score
against the sky and he has a rating like
a monster what's happening here said his
all-time high or something he had two
thousand seven hundred at one point Wow
okay surprising yeah I didn't want to
play three before I have cancelled okay
that's the kangaroo peed first never
quite sure
this is an absolute main line of the
Italian game with d3 and see you three
sorry for my voice I'm not sure what's
going on here I don't have a cold or
anything and I didn't it didn't pick up
smoking again or something crazy just
feels like um yeah it feels like a
slight cold so got some trades going on
mm but he's got a little bit got a
little bit better activity so that night
237 s what would try to get rid of it is
the idea was a weird sentence but um I
think you you get my my drift yeah most
terribly bored by this opening
Wow
Wow yes simply not much going on here I
know I tend to underestimate the
subtleties of those kind of nothing
positions but still I don't see what
white is doing here
and threatening to take you for f1 I
will upon any form what is he doing here
50 what's what's going on this one ok
what to bring the King around anyway so
not a big deal
taking this not a great idea but I
always wanted to bring it around to look
36 or something
we can take on d5 85 or somethings that
doing much I don't quite get it I don't
quite get what what is doing him
so he did take I guess pawn takes and
this and interesting he wants to locate
for me three
hmm check I'm not very happy with this
really like to get it over to see for
somehow it doesn't seem to work I'm
gonna charge us to success doing
anything good I'm probably not I see go
in g 5 now you know no it does
time warning very tough
I thought that this would be okay
actually I see having king of for Luke
g4g five traps this room this one oh my
god I Scott check here it's actually
made almost check check travel get your
check Wow map resigns Wow yeah I may be
played that very well from this nothing
position we came to something where um
only black can be better and he managed
to get a good position out of it like
here why don't I played you for you I
hokay i mean i don't know i mean i don't
think this is bad and per se but damn it
not exploiting what I had and here the
night on 85 this is interesting check
yeah I'm getting into slight roll
because the night only three is strong
it's really a strong piece and I think I
probably losing a bit of time now Jeff
Jeff I've not sure
I shouldn't come to HH maybe I am
definitely in some trouble it sir it's
awkward to play and after I have to move
the rock away now after g5 I'm probably
busted again I have to move it away at I
simply didn't and no this hits yeah this
is just this is just rude works arrow
key 5 mm yeah nicely played nicely
played by white yeah this is actually
quite mysterious and why do I don't I
played you form after that black is
quite them quite easily better I mean
without any problem something something
like that I'm just better night at five
yeah I mean whatever I can take I can go
to c6 can go F 6 which yeah yeah I
cannot be worse I really should should
take this opportunity I thought I have
time with this my actual idea was to
regroup the night and maybe like to see
5 or d6 to attack those pawns but it's
never materialized and here the sacking
of three is good it's million
I should just really go back and be
ready to just capture this here and this
is this is equal equal ish but you can
easily get into trouble as we have seen
I'm still a very weird play I have never
even heard of him that that person and
is like 27 and five minute wow that's
strong I have 50 people ever plus score
against the Moriya now it's fifty
percent so I don't know we must have
been lower at one point anyway thanks
for watching